what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today this is going
to be fun to check out here's a scoop of
what's going on this is sunday right now
on saturday two in the morning i
messaged warren causing wonder because i
came across an article from geekocity
mag mikey sutton he was talking about
when this spider-man trailer might come
out warren hadn't read that article yet
so he looked into it and then he started
pulling his sources around three in the
morning contacted some people then 12 30
pm got an update from a different person
within geekos city mag to find out where
this
source is from and then now here we have
a video from warren from those events
and i was like let's bring it full
circle for me contacting warren to now
let's react to warren's video what
additional information he was able to
find out because yeah the question is
really how reliable is the report i have
some suspicions as to why it wouldn't be
that time but let's see what's going on
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
right now there is a report going around
about when we can't expect to see the
spider-man no way home trailer with an
exact release time and if this report is
accurate then fans are about to be very
very happy of course at this point if
you have been keeping up with spider-man
no way home i think everybody knows that
we're expected to see a trailer or
footage at cinemacon which is on monday
now of course here is what fans want to
happen one they want it leaked obviously
somebody wants somebody to secretly
record the trailer and release it to the
public right that doesn't have a bad
idea we want a description of the
trailer which can definitely happen
because the people inside watching the
trailer can just go online and post it
anonymously but as it turns out we might
not actually have to wait for that as
the date and the time for marvel studios
this spider-man no way home trailer has
apparently leaked a couple of days ago
timbo over at the youtube channel the
lords of the long box told us that the
trailer is coming to the internet on
monday august 23rd at 8 00 a.m not too
long after that mikey sutin posted it to
his website
geekoccitymag.com and the report started
to make its way around the internet tim
vo mentioned it during his show and i've
actually spoken to timbo plenty of times
before in the past so i reached out to
him and i asked him what exactly he
heard and what he told me is that he has
a reliable source who has told him
information in the past that has been
accurate that has told him when to
expect the trailer which like i said is
this upcoming monday at 8am and he
believes this to be accurate since his
source has been reliable and the source
gave him an actual specific time the
weird part about what this report is
saying is a sony's usually 6 a.m so
that's what's kind of odd to me if
they're gonna do it it would be it's
usually six am would that mean they're
showing something else at cinemacon will
there be people there from spiderman no
way home intending to do some type of
presentation they gotta offer them
something more exclusive than just a
trailer over at cinemacon people are
paying a lot of money to go to that they
got to give them something else more
exclusive especially if they're going to
debut the trailer before cinemacon right
and the other part is shangqi review
embargo and i know this is this is a
sony thing not really a marvel thing
it's it's a little bit uh but the review
embargo for shanghai lives at 9 00 a.m
on monday so like this is a little bit
of like overlap kill to me because all
people are going to care about is the
spider-man trailer they're not really
tuning for the chong chi we're using
absolutely and i anticipate that most of
those are going to be very positive i
don't know let's see what else more is
here in the video but that's a big part
of why i'm a little bit skeptical to
believe it's 8 a.m but yeah i'm gonna be
awake anyway let's find out now the one
thing i had a question about is that i
knew sony's panel didn't start till at
night time but tim beau seems to think
that it's going to be a similar
situation to what happened at d23 we
will get a small glimpse of what's to
come and at cinemacon closed to the
public they will see what the internet
is going to see but they'll also see a
lot more perhaps a trailer plus footage
or just a longer trailer and who knows
what sony is going to release to the
public maybe we'll just get a trailer to
use 13 second teaser hopefully not
hopefully it's at least a minute but
we'll have to wait and see on that and
the logic is kind of here on this if
sony and of course marvel studios since
they're working together but mostly sony
as the president of marketing assad ayaz
has stated that sony is handling most of
it sony knows that fans are going to
talk about what they saw they know that
press is going to be there and they're
going to talk about that as well and
they know that even though security
precautions can be taken there of course
is always the possibility that somebody
could actually record footage of what
they saw and release it online
anonymously so if sony did want to get a
jump on these leaks and description
links getting out they would release it
beforehand that would be the smart move
and of course sony does usually release
things early on in the morning now
spider-man no way home may be different
because let's just face it this film is
different it's bigger if all three
spider-man truly are in the movie this
movie could literally break records of
avengers in-game and if i'm sony and i
wish i were because i would release the
trailer already but if i'm sony i'm
definitely releasing the footage before
fans have an opportunity to release it
themselves via leaks they want to be the
ones to release it they don't want their
fate controlled by leaks they want to
show us what they want to show us okay
this movie's gonna be a spider-verse
movie i'm suspecting that like right now
there's been some leak going around also
on the internet of like alfred molina
hello peter is rumored to be in the
trailer that's some leak that has been
going around if that's in the trailer i
think this would just be a very
different cinemacon situation versus how
cinemacon is usually done where
they wait a while after cinemacon to
then put the trailer publicly online if
there's anything
mind-blowing at all in this trailer if
there's anything mind-blowing that's
like a confirmation of the many things
we've heard anything of sinister six or
whatever that's gonna leak online right
away immediately so they might as well
just release this at very minimum after
it shows at cinemacon yeah very minimum
that seems like the option that would
make the least people angry yeah because
it takes a lot of the thunder out of you
being there and actually spending the
time to get there and the money and all
that stuff and two i mean you you want
that hyped i feel like to preempt the
trailer
instead of you know just kind of latch
onto it but despite all of these reports
i still want to keep my expectations at
just a description because that way if
something happens and sony decides not
to release any footage or a trailer i'm
not gonna be too disappointed but again
it does look like monday is the day and
i'm sure everybody is just stoked let me
know how excited you are in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
don't forget to follow me on twitter and
instagram for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
thanks for reporting on that buddy i'm
i'm a little uh i'm i'm a little
hesitant like yourself there are a lot
of people i saw bsl also talking they
were there once i heard about from the
um the whole thing with the hello peter
dockoff thing uh as a tease to come in
the trailer so yeah like i'm a little
hesitant but you know i'm also just
worried that we're gonna mainly i'm
mainly worried about just being on time
yeah
because that's like the main part is
like all right so i'm here at 8am i'm
here at 8pm i'm here at 6am tuesday and
so at this point it's it's like
difficult to make sure to like we just
want to give it the best video ever we
got our opening sketch we want the
reaction and the commentary afterwards
to just be the best it can be within
like a to make it just a solid like 8 to
10 minute video that's mainly my concern
is is that and being on top of it
because you know with what we do a lot
of it depends on that
but guys when do you think it's coming
what are you hoping with seeing it leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell hit that like button hey we'll
catch you guys soon